what's your favorite new impression
you've been working on oh I'm well the
one I did this morning I did the British
guy walking down the stairs my wife was
in the kitchen I thought she was wasn't
in the house
I practice impressions and I get caught
so I'm walking down the stairs I'm going
yeah something like what do you think of
this Trump fellow and then I saw her and
and I just started mumbling dududududu
just Excel you you do this when you're
walking around the house you you're
talking to yourself and making noises
and doing them totally and when I
learned Jeff Bridges I did it on a hike
I just saw hell or high water and I love
I love Jeff Bridges love Jeff Reggie so
I just I just started kind of doing that
you know I always you just kind of
swallow
we're loud man I'm we're just doing
playing he always sounds like you just
had a half of Angus beef and I'm on a
hike at Griffith Park and I'm just out
there I think alone and I think nobody
something like well numbers I'm going on
um I'm Hawking like nizzle we're gonna
get her giddyup home and go live like
that and then I see a hiker come he sees
me and the guy walks by I'm in Hollywood
right he goes hey were you doing Jeff
Bridges so that's one of my new
favorites along we like you like Jeff
Bridges and and you think that is there
a reason why he talks that way now I
think it informs his acting choices like
he it makes his belt really tight eats a
lot of food and then you just got this
calves from kind of acting you don't
push too hard you're just sometimes
you're over does it I'm no good right
now you better I can't I better jump I'm
about to give birth I wanna make and
there go we'll only have one line Jeff
just say they're gonna come find us
alright roll of caramel take my cue
[Music]
well they're gonna come find us